bonne nouvelle à partir du 11 janvier
prochain vous lancez votre campagne de
financement les beaux quatre heures pour
votre fondation si je pense votre plus
beau projet parce que c'est un hommage à
votre frère Christian tu es une accident
d'auto à cause de ça tu as plus de
mémoire immédiaire ni des missions
comment j'ai eu j'ai adoré votre message
publié sur Facebook en ou 2021 où vous
racontez justement le jour de l'accident
oui j'ai fait ça c'est vrai et j'ai
l'impression que derrière l'humoriste
baveux l'homme sûr de lui et un être
vraiment sensible oui très juste tu me
dis ça oh si je me rappelais même pas
j'avais écrit ça mais c'est vrai que
c'était c'est que mon frère on a un an
de différence on est tout temps ensemble
on couche dans le même chambre depuis
qu'on est tout petit du jour au
lendemain tu te lèves le matin tu
déjeunes tout seul et puis là donc c'est
une catastrophe de vie épouvantable
c'est mon meilleur ami on a les mêmes
amis alors
ça a été vraiment quelque chose c'est
vrai que j'avais écrit ça un petit peu
la journée parce que on est à
l'imparfait et puis le matin on partait
du Nord c'est là qu'il y a eu son
accident et puis c'est toutes des
petites choses de vie est assez en
arrière on à l'époque on mettait pas de
ceinture de sécurité en arrière ce qui
est un peu ridicule c'était deux pieds
en arrière
du passager puis lui et ceux qui avaient
leur ceinture ont rien eu donc mon frère
à partir de là sa vie a été finie puis
la mienne est celle de notre famille a
été bouleversée beaucoup tu sais faire
quoi c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
sensible je pense que l'humour m'aide à
traverser ça les monologues que j'ai
écrit les émissions avec les beaux
malaises ça me permet de
vivre et d'évacuer je peux c'est des
choses avec lesquelles j'ai de la
difficulté à parler je peux pleurer très
facilement quand je vois dans ces
sujets-là
après je me suis Martin juste d'être là
derrière Martin Matt l'humoriste
se cache je pense aussi un homme
d'affaires red
ben écoute redoutable je sais pas un
homme d'affaires sans équivoque c'est ça
j'étais ça avant d'être humoristes moi
ça j'ai grandi là-dedans mon père est un
vendeur un homme d'affaires et j'ai
travaillé pour lui j'ai étudié un
administration donc et j'aime ça quand
je suis sorti de l'école de l'humour je
jouais d'un barbe j'avais une paye puis
je m'étais ouvert deux comptes au
guichet pour mettre 30 % dans un autre
compte pour éventuellement l'impôt à
payer puis je me rappelle j'avais croisé
Anthony Cavana puisque moi j'étais le
petit nouveau
scène dis-moi tu as pris quatre ans
payer mes impôts j'ai des yeux
à organiser c'est pas une corvée c'est
une petite
votre obsession du moment c'est de
préparer votre prochain torkshow 2023
vous voulez faire quelque chose de
complètement différent votre idole c'est
Dévi de Letterman est-ce que ça va être
un croisement entre le petit méchant et
la semaine des quatre jolies pas du tout
tu as donné deux chats
[Rires]
pour dire ce que ça sera pas et non ça
va être oui les revenus je l'aime
beaucoup mais nous ça va être un gros
show de variété le meilleur terme c'est
hors chaud parce qu'on connaît le plus
mais il va beaucoup beaucoup d'humour il
va avoir un invité avec lequel il y a
des concepts parce que je te parle c'est
je souris seul parce que on a fait un
radage moi je travaille beaucoup en
amont alors je regarde mes choux quand
je publie c'est là j'ai rodé mon torque
chose
avec des invités dans une petite salle
et ça on a fait ça ça fait 48 heures
c'était vraiment une super soirée ça
marchait la formule des idées en tout
cas que que j'avais qu'on inventé avec
les auteurs puis qui fonctionne très
bien donc c'est un projet qui m'excite
beaucoup beaucoup les beaux malaises de
Point Zéro se termine avec Martin mat au
bord d'un lac à quand les baumes à
lèvres 3.0 je pense ça va venir je pense
ça va venir parce que j'ai eu le Breton
m'avait tapé sur l'épaule en deux scènes
on riait elle avait dit ça faisait 5 ans
qu'on avait fini les baumes à lèvres
je devrais faire ça à chaque 5 voir où
on est rendu
puis après ça on a tourné notre scène
j'arrête pas de penser à ça puis j'ai
dit c'est vrai c'est de voir et là pour
le moment je parle là-dedans du tout
mais je serais vraiment pas surpris que
dans deux ans un an 3 ans je m'assois
puis je me dis qu'il est rendu alors je
suis rendu crevons l'abcès parce que sur
les internets il y a des rumeurs qui
circulent les gens veulent savoir on
voit sur certaines photos très heureux
la main en l'air comme ça et vous
montrer le grand amour qui vous
passionne en ce moment la moto oui la
moto c'est c'est quoi non non c'est
exactement ça ouais disons-le c'est une
façon de vous évader pour vous la moto
on voit avec trois gars en arrière oui
j'arrive de Vegas on a mis Daniel
grenier qui était dans les chicken swell
eu 50 ans et on est parti il y avait moi
martin-périsolo my world Daniel mais ils
font pas tous la moto donc on est parti
moi Daniel et un de ses amis François
puis on a été dans la vallée du Nevada
dans le désert c'était la plus de la
moto de ma vie donc ce qui est moto
marque au repos si on veut mais plus qui
moto à l'occasion surtout des rails
comme ça là ça j'avoue que c'est unique
tu prends une journée tu t'en vas dans
le désert avec des amis ça c'est assez
solide mais plus qui Martin match j'ai
bien hâte de vous reparler pour votre
torchon 2023 merci beaucoup c'est un
plaisir merci à toi merci